moi j'ai jamais eu de frère je ne
possède pas une nature divine qui me
permettent en même temps d'être ici et
là j'avais une soeur que les vagues ont
englouti par charité qu'elle gagne at-il
entre nous deux qu'elle payait de vous
de quel nom de quelle famille dessus de
messaline si bastien était mon père
j'avais mon frère sébastien pariez vous
porter ses vêtements quand il fut
engloutie dans les flots si vous étiez
d'une femme tous concorderait si bien
que je bannirai vosges ou de mes larmes
et que je vous dirais soit trois fois la
bienvenue maintenant au phrasé viola
vous père avait un signe sur le front le
mien aussi
il mourut le jour où viola compter sa
13e année il termina en effet sa vie
mortelle
le jour où ma soeur eu présent rien ne
s'oppose plus à ce que nous soyons
heureux ensemble
sauf que ce costume masculin que j'ai
emprunté pour vous convaincre
je vous emmènerai près de ce capitaine
qui est dans cette ville chez qui j'ai
laissé mes vêtements de jeunes filles
c'est grâce à son aide bienveillante jeu
fut sauvée pour servir ce noble duc
depuis lors toutes les vicissitudes de
ma fortune se dérouler entre cette dame
ce seigneur
[Musique]